TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
This week, France hosts the
5th International Conference
on Learning
Representations, which
is focused on how one can
learn meaningful and useful
representations of data
for machine learning.
Click through to the
post to learn more
about Google's research
being presented there.
Cloud Speech API, our automatic
speech recognition service,
is now generally available.
It's built on the
core technology
that powers speech recognition
for other Google products,
including Google Search, Google
Now, and Google Assistant.
But it has been adapted to
better fit the needs of Google
Cloud customers.
Head on over to the post to
learn about the latest features
and how to get started.
Dart 1.23 is now available.
It introduces support
for overwriting fields
in strong mode, along with
a lot of other improvements.
Notable changes and the
download link are on the post.
Smart Display
Campaigns have begun
rolling out to all
advertisers, letting
you reach more customers easily
on the Google Display Network.
These campaigns use the power
of Google's machine learning
to automatically
connect your business
to prospective customers who may
be interested in your products,
create beautiful image,
native, and text ads,
and set the right bids to
meet your performance goals.
A screenshot and some
data are on the post.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
I know you'd like
to see some more.
That's why we provided these
wonderful links right over here
for you to click on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]